A tsunami brought by the eruption oft the
volcano Krakatao has left this costal village
called Lentera behind me in rubble.
It is in this rubble that a young father hopes
he will find his three month old baby who
has been missing since Saturday.
The baby girl's name is Annisa.
Her body could be somewhere in this debris.
Ferry Kurniawan, a fisherman, is her father.
He lived with his wife Hanna and their three
children near the water's edge.
Their bamboo hut couldn't withstand the force
of the giant wave.
"This is all that's left of our house.
My mother asked about the strange sound outside
and when I looked out, I saw 3 big waves,
one after the other.
I panicked and woke up my wife.
We ran out with the whole family.
This (points to his right side) is where I
got hit by the first wave, but we kept running.
Over there (points to his left side) came
the second wave.
We fell again...and that's when our baby was
torn from my wife's arms.
We're still looking for her."
In this small village of about 50 residents,
three people were unaccounted for.
Two bodies have been found.
But Ferry’s baby girl is still missing.
This home is where Ferry and Hanna reunited
with two of their children instead of three.
"My baby was just wearing the new clothes
I had bought for her.
She had some new toys too, and she had just
started to smile and laugh.
We wanted to go to a family gathering but
when the waves came, I couldn't hold onto
her tight enough.
I lost her.
The tsunami left Hanna and Ferry's family
with only the clothes on their backs.
And for now, all they have is this picture of Annisa and the hope that she will be found.